thierry alors alors qu'il s'est fait je
me suis fait draguer par justin bieber
c'est sûr que chez vous sur ces vous
ouais pas vous non cabanons vous fermer
ses poussettes des t bonds récole rigolo
quizas et on s'est croisé deux fois fois
paris et une fois à cannes et la fois on
s'est vus sur paris on et j'étais avec
des amis et il est parti voir des potes
à lui lui a dit oui
ramenez moi el moudja ça m'a pas trop
cul ouais et donc il ya renoue avec un
orangina sur un plateau à turin mais je
suis parti voir avec des copines et il
nous parlait pas trop nos conseillers du
bahut les pas rigolo donc on est
retournés savate soirée et je le
recroise et l'année d'après à cannes
ouais et là il m'a dit cette fois-ci
danse pour moi non plus folle et je lui
ai dit mais à jamais la vie en fait mais
alors et bahebeck dupouy il était vexé
où il a demandé à ce que je quitte
l'endroit ou non
ouais voilà c'est assez triste comme
l'histoire parce que c'est pas ça
indochine bieber ah oui c'est un goujat
c'est un goujat c'est bon